[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans point de
vue c'est la dernière émission de la
semaine donc nous allons tout donner ce
soir avec nos quatre invités pour
débattre de l'actualité la plus
immédiate
voici en quelques mots le sommaire de
cette émission nous allons nous
intéresser aux suites de la sphère qui
de dénonciation des agressions sexuelles
on voit la mafia pas la secrétaire
d'état chargée de l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes qui prépare un
projet de loi sur ce sujet et puis la
polémique rebondit après les accusations
portées contre pierre joxe nous allons
aussi parler de marine le pen elle était
hier à l'émission politique de france 2
le front national est toujours pas très
au clair pour savoir s'il faut ou non
ont quitté leur os qu'il faut jouer ça à
pile ou face
est-ce qu'il faut prendre une position
un peu plus clair et bien nous allons
évidemment en débattre nous parlerons
aussi de la droite la droite des
territoires celle des départements des
communes des régions bref des
collectivités locales à ses critiques
contre le gouvernement en lui reprochant
une baisse des dotations sa console
invoqué que vous voyez ici le président
de la région auvergne rhône at mais pas
seulement et puis nous parlerons d'art
contemporain une fois n'est pas coutume
avec la fiac le grand rendez vous de la
profession qui s'est lancé hier c'est au
grand palais et ça se passe jusqu'à
dimanche
bonsoir à notre quatre invités qui ont
accepté d'être avec nous bonsoir
benjamin grange
vous êtes le président de dentsu
consulting votre spécialité c'est la
réputation la notoriété des entreprises
en particulier sur internet mais pas que
bonsoir hervé nathan bonsoir directeur
adjoint de la rédaction de marianne en
couverture de marianne cette semaine à
un dossier exceptionnel sur 20 ans vous
soulagé après votre âge
venez donc très heureux de vous
souhaiter un bon anniversaire à vous et
surtout à votre magazine 20 ans
d'articles de marianne dont certains de
signature qui nous sont familières comme
natacha polony absence mais pas
seulement bon soir laurence de charette
vous êtes la directrice de la rédaction
du figaro.fr le site internet du figaro
et bonsoir je dis deviennent trop
journalistes et à la rédaction du figaro
magazine figaro magazine dont je montre
la couverture puisque il est depuis ce
matin dans les kiosques nous sommes
intéressés aux relations parfois
difficiles ou plus exactement addictives
entre les enfants et les écrans peut-on
les sevrer de ce genre de pratiques est
souhaitable comment faire on essaie de
répondre à cette question dans notre
numéro mais ça n'est pas l'objet de
points de vue ce soir on fait donc
s'intéresser d'abord à lausanne affaire
grave de harcèlement sexuel vous savez
que les déclarations les révélations se
multiplient
il ya eu sept hashtag balances ton port
où des femmes victimes d'agressions
sexuelles que dénonce leur agresseur il
semblerait qu'il y ait une un consensus
sur la nécessité de ce genre de
dénonciation consensus en tout cas
politique à gauche mais aussi à droite
vous propose d'écouter ce qu'en disait
ce matin nicolas des pompes
dupont-aignan le président de debout la
france c'était sur france info j'ai vu
l'omerta dans mon département à ce point
je l' ai vu je jeu j'ai été l'un des des
seuls candidats à la présidentielle a
proposé des mesures radicales sur le
harcèlement peines planchers jeu enfin
il ya une prise de conscience dans notre
société
tous les responsables politiques parlent
d'une voix sur ce sujet il y avait bruno
le maire qui avait dit que il était
plutôt contre ce genre de pratique c'est
à dire des dénonciations et puis ensuite
il a rétropédalé amusant mais non j'ai
été mal compris j'ai une veine troubles
on pense forcément la même chose sur un
sujet comme celui là ou bien est ce que
peut y avoir des nuances non pas sur le
principe de la condamnation de deux des
agressions sexuelles mais sur le moyen
de les dénoncer
alors toute nuance sur cette campagne
dont le hashtag je le rappelle ses
balances ton port est perçue comme une
tentative de banalisation
des faits de harcèlement agressions
sexuelles viols donc c'est quasiment
impossible
et d'ailleurs la vidéo de ces
pathétiques de bruno le maire faisant
pénitence et regrettant d'avoir agi
dit-il au mot délation est pas la
gravité des faits et invoqué même dit
assez bien à quel point il est
impossible de ne pas être en accord de
ne pas applaudir de ne donne pas même
surenchérir sur cette campagne à
laquelle je trouve personnellement
beaucoup de défauts alors peut être
qu'on y reviendra
je propose de devenir tout de suite à ce
qui est le l'actualité la plus immédiate
ariane fornia qui est une fille d'eric
besson l'ancien ministre nicolas sarkozy
a dénoncé sur son blog une agression
sexuelle dont elle affirme avoir été
l'objet de la part de pierre joxe claire
joxe vous savez ces sept personnalités
éminentes du parti socialiste ancien
ministre de l'intérieur et de la défense
de françois mitterrand ancien président
de la cour des comptes se faire lors de
ma part ariane fornia le-le-le accuse
d'avoir procédé à des attouchements
c'était pendant un concert à l'opéra
bastille
mais pierre joxe lui nie absolument je
vous propose d'écouter sa réponse
c'était ce matin sur europe 1 tendez
bien l'oreille parce qu'il est au
téléphone
l'express et qu'est ce qu'on raconte les
informant le moment pas vous souvenez de
cet opéra en l'occurrence je ne fais pas
de lesquels elle parle je vais assez
souvent en céréales au coeur ce que vous
comptez intervenir ce que c'est pas du
tout c'est tellement bizarre comme
situation tellement insolite que je
réfléchir à ça alors je parle de
l'express parce que celle d'exxon ce
sont nos confrères de l'express qui ont
sorti l'information et l'affirmation
d'ariane fornia hervé nathan on voit là
le la difficulté de ce genre de pratique
dénonciation publique
mais c'est parole contre parole oui
c'est très très compliqué en général
d'abord c'est parole contre parole donc
on est obligé données apport au lot 2 et
d'écouter les deux là seul moyen qu'on
voit éventuellement de trancher à celui
très frileux tranché le vrai du faux
ce serait éventuellement un procès en
diffamation si ça ne me trompe pas c'est
prescrit donc ça pourrait pause on va se
retrouver dans la situation qu'on a vu
dans d'autres affaires où il ya une
prescription donc ne pas juger le fait
lui-même donc on va juger si ces
diffamations ou pas en général c'est pas
bon pour les victimes
en tout cas celle qui se présente tel
c'est à ce parent ça se termine assez
mal donc c'est pas une solution
je pense que c'est pas une solution le
problème du hashtag qui pour moi était
un mouvement d'opinion extraordinaire je
suis pour à lens devant valence ton port
parce que tout d'un coup on se rend
compte de la profondeur de du mal qui
est fait aux deux qui est fait aux
femmes voilà tout d'un coup non non et
débarque maintenant on débarque pas
complètement mais le 11e ce que je
voulais souligner ce qui est un moment
il ya bien une forme d'impasse faire que
ça c'est un mouvement d'opinion et ça
permet de poser le problème parce que
peut-être qu'on ne pose pas assez
souvent et c'est sans doute ça qui fait
qu'ils menaient vite un problème est que
mais moi je pense que par ailleurs la
judiciarisation il ya des limites à sa
d'abord parce que c'est très difficile
pour les victimes
ça se termine pas forcément bien pour le
moment les tribunaux sont pas forcément
favorables regardez ce qui est arrivé il
ya une histoire à l'assemblée nationale
elle est terminé et maintenant c'est
c'est s'est lancé le député hommes qui
portent plainte pour diffamation parce
que comme c'est prescrit maintenant des
confrères on va même plus corsée voilà
on peut même plus parler on veut même
plus en parler
par ailleurs moi j'ai puisqu'on a fait
un dossier là dessus moi je suis obligé
quelque chose qui m'a un peu interloqué
c'est que il ya une demande de
judiciarisation énorme et donc de
sanction de répression très forte c'est
sans doute justifiée et il ya une
permissivité de la société et des
pouvoirs politiques sur 1,52 choses qui
sont pour moi des faits générateurs du
harcèlement sexuel je parle la
pornographie sur internet je signale que
les enfants arrivent à accéder à 8 ans 9
ans 10 ans 11 ans il accède à la
pornographie sur internet on va pas
faire un tableau sur ce que c'est que la
pornographie sur internet c'est un appel
au viol c'est le dire le corps des
femmes est disponible aux hommes c'est
grosso modo ça c'est des cd vidéo de 3
minutes
il se joue peut-être le rap aussi non
mais j'ai pas voilà donc il ya en tout
cas il ya des lois en france sur la
protection des mineurs attention
maintenant je voulais y aller voir et ça
on les applique pas le professeur israël
nisand que le gynécologue spécifiant
président du collège français d une
clope social ça fait des années qu'il
alerte la dessus il a essayé de pau
d'alerter les pouvoirs publics personne
n'a rien fait parce que ça c'est pas
chic
ça fait c'est pas bien de celle pas chic
d'aller d'aller les d'aller regarder ce
qui se passe sur internet et surtout de
dire on va verrouiller folie demande un
truc très simple il y à qu'a exigé le
paiement à la première image en disant à
la première image pornographique pour
l'avoir il faut mettre laquelle il faut
donner son numéro de carte bleue ça ce
serait efficace et très simple à faire
c'est beaucoup plus simple qu'on pense
et ça personne ne le proposera tout d'un
coup il ya plus personne
mais il ya une génération entière qui
est en train d'apprendre sur internet
qu'on peut violer les femmes et que ça
leur fait du bien parce que c'est ça ce
qui se passe sur internet lance de
charef à mon avis ce que vous expliquez
souligne à quel point ce hashtag
finalement est il approprié ou en tout
cas il est réducteur il est vexatoire et
confiscatoires d'abord évidemment
l'arrêter le chiffre existe là bas on
l'a encore souligné nous dans le
vieillard aujourd'hui c'est à dire une
femme sur deux a déjà été confronté le
phénomène sociétal existe maintenant la
question c'est est-ce que ce hashtag
c'est la bonne façon de lutter à mon
avis il
et vexatoire pour les hommes évidemment
mais pour les femmes également pour fils
catoire d'ailleurs la personne qui la
voient comme des victimes des victimes
par destination et de façon un peu
obligatoire et systématique et c'est
assez infantilisant comme comme
d'ailleurs la personne qui a lancé ce
hashtag elle-même bon je sais que c'est
pas très élégant gelé lancé comme ça et
donc il est d'ailleurs les américains se
sont contentés de moi aussi peut-être
que moi aussi serait mieux que balances
ton port et est qu un torrent en qu'un
déversement de dénonciations anonymes
qui sont confiscatoire à mon avis parce
que ce n'est pas la paix c'est ça ne
nous prive du vrai débat qui se joue
plus là où vous dites c'est à dire le
vrai débat c'est la formation des
policiers qui doivent entendre ce genre
de plainte c'est les vraies mesures etc
donc on reste à côté de l'efficacité et
à mon avis il ya une autre chose c'est
qu'on on est pris dans un piège de
guerre des sexes et surtout de nous
entre islamisme et puritanisme dans les
rapports dans les rapports amoureux ou
affectif en tout cas dans les rapports
hommes femmes
on est prisonnier de cette espèce de
bulle est alors qu'alain française
auparavant jusqu'à pas si longtemps on
savait en sortir il réellement quand
même avant gère des harcèlements feu le
débordement de la de la drague à
accepter ou harcèlement il a il existe
depuis extrêmement longtemps
bon oui ça c'est sorti je venais n'a pas
réagi tout de suite juste en projetant
l'instant le réfère d'un sondage réalisé
par le doc ça pour le figaro et ensutie
benjamin on va revenir sur d'autres
éléments de sondage qui montre que 57%
des français approuvent l'initiative de
ce hashtag pendant ce trop court alors
c'est une grosse coupe c'est une
majorité forte mais en même temps c'est
pas l'unanimité sa montre donc un
certain nombre de réserves dont vous
faites état ici peut-être que les
français les partages judith waintraub
oui je voulais ajouter ce que disait
laurent ce que c'est le règne de la
confusion puisque
le port n'est pas caractérisée par ses
agissements
on décrète de la personne qui sans plat
sur twitter des crêtes qui est un porc
ça peut aller
du sifflement delà de la remarque
sexiste dans le micro dans le métro au
viol mettre tout ça dans le même sac
c'est évidemment pas recevable et ça
exactement comme disait laurence le
résultat contraire à celui escompté
c'est que saab à d'alice a aplati tout
ça ça me la confusion partout au lieu de
mettre de la clarté et de la précision
deuxième chose une fois que votre nom a
été balancée comme port comme harceleur
vous pouvez faire un procès en
diffamation mais que vous ne perdiez ou
que vous le gagnez qu'est ce qui se
passe pour votre réputation dans votre
milieu professionnel dans votre famille
le mal est fait et on le sait très bien
normalement moi je voulais revenir sur
ce qui s'était dit sur les réseaux
sociaux depuis que sandra muller le 13
octobre a lancé ce hashtag balances ton
port finalement on a on a noté presque 3
135 mille messages et on verra dans les
sujets suivants que c'est absolument
énorme sur sur cette période là alors
évidemment cette initiative
elle a libéré la parole est révélé
l'ampleur de la souffrance
et quand on regarde la topographie des
messages qu'est ce qu'on voit on va
retrouver des témoignages d'agressions
et d'harcèlement
on va retrouver une mise en exergue du
sexisme ordinaire ou de la pression
subie par les femmes
parfois les témoignages de soutien et
solidarité et de solutions et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que ces messages 61%
ont été postées par des femmes avec sur
les 40 % restants
finalement des témoignages d'hommes qui
venait en soutien de ces messages de
femmes donc par là même sa rejoint
comment dire ce sondage que nous avons
réalisé hier où on disait que cette
question du harcèlement sexuel et des
agressions est un problème important
pour 91% des français
alors après la question véritablement
que ça pose c'est est-ce que internet et
les réseaux sociaux doit être une forme
de tribunal populaire parce que sur
l'ensemble de ces 335 milles message il
y a dix sept mille témoignages qui sont
des témoignages d'agressions et
d'harcèlement et parmi ceux-là seuls une
dizaine qu'on porte un nom alors est ce
que véritablement au delà d'avoir libéré
la parole
on encourage la délation est en tout cas
ce qui est sûr c'est que terme de porc
fait réagir c'est à dire que il le
révèle une forme de violence
et quand on regardait ce sondage où les
français sont très partagés et bien 43 %
d'entre eux disent où l initiative on la
rejette
justement pour cette partie des lattes
war et cette partie est liée finalement
à ce mot de porc et âme à la tentation
ça dépend parce que c'est le mieux la
délation et surtout le lieu de nommer
son agresseur est ce que c est
exactement ce qu il faut dire aussi
c'est que dans le même sondage donc
réalisé par doxa pour le figaro france
info et dentsu il ya une la moitié des
femmes qui disent
nous avons g qui disent avoir subi une
agression au cours de leur vie north de
chat ça vous paraît mois ce chiffre me
paraît énorme et si mais ce que vous il
vous a surpris
non on a fait beaucoup de sujets
récemment et on voit qu'effectivement
ces interprètes de société on voit que
les il ya sept 7 femmes sur instagram
qui a pris qu'ils prenaient en photo les
personnes qui souhaitent bon voilà bon
je crois qu'il faut tenir compte de
cette réalité qui existe il ne s'agit
pas de la nied messages issus de la
prendre par le bon bout on parle
d'harcèlement un pas deux pas
d'agression moi ça me paraît très peu ce
que je connais fais un crochet je
comprenais pas une consoeur qui n'en ai
pas été victime une fois voire plusieurs
fois dans sa vie pas une on est allé on
est allé plus loin dans ce sondage pour
savoir finalement quels étaient les
comportements qui était le prénom si
voilà parce que c'est là que se situe
c'est là finalement voilà soixante
ul-haq de la question est alors je vais
est extrêmement précise que comme c'est
un homme qui le dit c'est jamais très
facile faire un compliment sur le
physique ou la tenue d'une personne que
vous ne connaissez pas et bien c'est un
comportement non répréhensible pour 80%
des français
la nation française c'est conforme à la
loi
pour la formalisation c'est qu'en
revanche les marseillais ont commencé
point beaucoup plus nuancée
quand on dit sifflé une fille ou un
garçon dans la rue c'est répréhensible
pour 51 sergio guerre des français new
york partie répréhensible est un
compliment estime que c'est oui c'est un
comportement à avoir et en tout cas
c'était un compliment
et puis ensuite on tient le reste le
reste évidemment le reste évidemment
quand on voit plus loin c'est
unanimement considéré comme comme
répréhensible
encore un mot là-dessus sur les
statistiques
selon leurs statistiques et essor qui
publié quelques qui publie régulièrement
ses des enquêtes de victimation et les
chiffres sur le viol et les agressions
sexuelles sont absolument effrayant les
cinq victimes nous explique que yacco
20%
voilà déjà la rance et oui quand on fait
je crois qu'ils font d un il faut une
extrapolation
enfin bref j'ai en tout cas c'est
effrayant c'est effrayant et on va pas
discuter des niveaux
et d'une certaine façon alors que depuis
une vingtaine d'années même 30 ans l'a
par exemple la répression du viol je me
souviens - du combat des féministes pour
faire reconnaître le viol comme un crime
alors qu'avant c'était très souvent
correctionnalisés donc le quantum des
peines est pas le même cetera c'était
dans les années 70 80
ça a été un combat à mener donc on a
l'impression c'est là où j'en reviens à
la limite d'âge judiciarisation et au et
l'absence à mon avis d'éducation de la
jeunesse parce que dans le même temps qu
on a augmenté la juderia saison la
répression et les lois répressives
d'une certaine manière on a un petit peu
déserté ce qui était le ski était la
tâche des adultes c'est à dire des ducs
et d'éduquer les jeunes n'est que
d'éduquer les enfants
il ya une loi de 2004 c'est toujours je
parle sous le jeu retranscrit ce que ce
qu'a dit il sera une mise en il ya une
loi de 2000 2004 qui prévoit le début de
l'éducation n'ont pas sexuel mais
l'éducation ceux des enfants respect du
corps et le respect de l'autre
cette loi n'est pas appliquée le prévoit
depuis l'âge à partir de l'âge de 4 ans
dans les écoles
il doit y avoir une éducation des jeunes
de plus en plus en fait qui évidemment
différente sous un visage est là elle a
notamment elle s'est arrêtée et je sais
que celle s'est arrêtée au moment où le
gouvernement a décidé de renoncer aux
abc l'éducation alors je sais que les
adc l'éducation c'est très content et ça
le sera mais dans les avc d'une question
il y avait une partie très importante
qui était d'apprendre aux gars ont
respecté les filles et c'était
normalement le plus est le principal
objet c'est pas le problème le problème
c'est que là pour le moment il ne se
passe plus rien du tout et donc pour le
moment et je reviens à ce qu'il n'y ait
pour le moment les yeux si vous ça aussi
ce que ce que les jeunes garçons ce que
c'est que le corps d'une femme
ils vont aller regarder sur internet
voilà il revient le monde alors pas en
mai dans une famille oui au nom de ses
parents
j'ai pas de quelle génération vient
toquer moi j'ai pas demandé à mes
parents parce que ça se faisait pas à
cette époque là je pense qu'on est quand
même un certain nombre comme ça mais
effectivement il ya donc là il ya encore
des corps
les départs en pologne les parents
peuvent on est pas la noire plus pour
juger les parents il se trouve que nous
sommes ce seigneur me décrire et à
sécuriser il ya des lois il ya une loi
sur la protection de la jeunesse pas
appliquée alors que normalement un
journal porno par exemple il doit être
au fond du coeur
il est pas en accès libre et très bien
nous sommes tous journalistes ici
vraiment en revanche sur internet la
pornographie c'est de l'accès libre pour
tous les gens et il ya une loi sur
l'éducation des jeunes qui devrait être
à l'école c'est une loi de la république
pas appliquée non plus avec ça on va
dire ah oui mais vous rendez compte
qu'il ya de plus en plus d'agressions
bah oui elle plus en plus de la passion
excusait
mais le jeu musical
il faut l'accepter et ils véhiculent
très souvent je pas toujours très
souvent une image de la prennent
absolument mais leur attente
oui mais bon voilà en tout cas sur le
rôle sur le rôle des parents sur le rôle
des parents est notamment pour l'accès
des enfants à la pornographie et la la
la limitation absolue qui doit en être
faite je vous renvoie au dossier du
figaro magazine sur les enfants et
l'écran en passant d'un autre sujet on
va parler de marine le pen on a beaucoup
dit que la volonté du front national de
sortir de l'euro avait été
contre-productif marine le pen pendant
la campagne présidentielle
on avait compris que finalement elle
était revenue sur cette idée sauf que
c'est encore un petit peu compliqué dans
sa tête apparemment la présidente du
front national était hier à l'émission
politique sur france 2 hier soir
et quand on lui a posé une question
claire etes-vous pour ou contre la
sortie de l'euro et bien la réponse là
était un peu moins
jugez vous même mais ce que vous nous
dites ce soir clément clairement que
vous demandez toujours la sortie de
l'euro à terme nous allons voir
nous allons voir oui c'était on a été
surpris par la brièveté de la réponse je
pense que les téléspectateurs l'ont été
aussi
comment est-ce que vous comment est ce
que vous expliquez ça j'ai du vintrou
vous pensez que l a toujours pas d'idée
sur la question non mais là elle a
quasiment donné l'explication avec
presque une naïveté qu'on n'avait pas
l'habitude de voir chez elle en disant à
mes électeurs ne suivait pas donc il
fallait bien que je change sur ce point
le problème c'est que ce programme
économique ne tenait que dans la
perspective d'une sortie de l'euro et de
l'europe
c'est comme si vous enleviez la pierre
angulaire d'un édifice matou s'écoule
veux pas revenir à la retraite à 60 ans
et proposer le programme extrêmement
sociale qu'elle propose en restant en
europe
donc elle est bien embêté j'ai bien aimé
l'expression de françois lenglet qui a
dit sur le plateau elle n'a pas réussi à
décroiser ses skis sur l'euro on a
vraiment cette impression même si parce
que quand point de vue on essaie de
respecter l'intellectuel la plus totale
marine le pen a aussi expliqué que ça
allait dépendre des résultats qu'on
pouvait obtenir par rapport à la banque
centrale européenne donc donc elle a été
un peu plus développer son propos même
si encore une fois elle semblait assez
peu décidée sur la conduite à tenir
valentin pilates du figaro.fr nous a
rejoint bonsoir valentin ce qu'est ce
qu'on dit sur les réseaux sociaux des
déclarations de marine le pen sur ce
sujet alors cette influence sur
l'audience mais c'est aussi un flop sur
les réseaux réflexe l'audience et qu'il
y avait moins de monde à l'émission
politique d'hier que par exemple dans
celle de deux des leurs philippe le
produit net voilà exactement si on
compare l'audience tout comme les tweets
par exemple qui ont eu hier soir on en a
eu seulement 23 milles hier avec le
hashtag l'émission politique vous fait
concurrence à voir j'ai ma grange leur
principe c'est lui qui nous révèle tout
ça on verra si vos chiffres sont raccord
d'affaires un nouveau livre donc c'est
trois fois moins que edouard philippe le
28 septembre dernier
donc sur cette émission on retrouve
celles et ceux qui diront c'est bien
c'est pas bien quelques tweets ironique
et les patriotes
c'était la première fois pour eux deux
d'avoir l'occasion vraiment de
s'exprimer sur le cas de viol les amis
de florian philippot donc la majorité
des truites sont comme négatif il faut
le dire mais d'un naturel optimiste mais
positivisme fera que je commence avec
l'étude positif c'est la communauté des
fans
à commencer par les à une marine calme
mais ferme claire honnête et reposé très
bonne prestation de marine bravo nous
dit-elle sur l'euro vous avez même
laetitia qui défend marine le pen je
n'ai jamais eu peur de sortir de l'euro
place aux commentaires plus sévère sur
le site internet du figaro notamment
brigade on le 7 mai 2010 est à la rater
un rendez vous important avec les
français
mais il ne se reproduira plus et son
relookage souriant et apaisé ne changera
rien nous dit elle
quand c'est l'heure c'est l'heure après
c'est trop tard
la surenchère de rôdeur toujours sur le
site internet du figaro le fn est
inaudible depuis la présidentielle
sa présidente a montré ses limites le
parti est revenu à ses origines et
finira groupusculaire nous dire odeurs
en embuscade
donc les patriotes sans pitié florian
philippot darmanin veut supprimer l isf
pour les revenus financiers marine le
pen lisf pour l'immobilier oui et qu'en
pensent les français nous demandent
florian philippot
l'ancienne conseillère du fn notamment
sophie montel s'interroge madame le pen
a entendu les français sur leur au camp
puisqu'il n'ya gel puisqu'il n'y a
jamais eu de vrai référendum sur le
sujet voilà donc guillaume on le voit
bien le débat au final sur l'euro n'est
pas réglé la roumaine a tancé c'est une
histoire un des merdes abl si vous me
permettez l'expression
non mais ça fait un bail à la
démonstration est faite hier soir que le
la cohérence que florian philippot
incarne vraiment pour moi la cohérence
du programme économique et par une
licence lui il sort un gros point énorme
et parce qu'à partir du moment où vous
êtes un parti nationaliste parlons les
choses comme elles sont pour moi est un
parti nationaliste ont dit souverainiste
d'un parti nationaliste la nation
appartement voulait une nation et la
cohérence vous une nation des frontières
est une monnaie enfin bon elle a déroulé
et en même temps elle est incapable de
soutenir une situation comme ça l'autre
solution pour les partis nationalistes
pour ceux qui viennent de l'extrême
droite c'est de dire une europe nation
avec une référence est ce que voulait
faire les allemands de l'europe entre
1940 et 44 points évidemment c'est pas
c'est pas l'objectif de marine disons
que dans l'ancien front national dans
l'avenir moment sa naissance il y avait
quelques personnalités fondatrice du
front national dont c'était l'option de
départ puisqu'il y en avait quelques-uns
qui était la waffen ss donc voilà mais
c'est pas du tout marine le pen donc
elle est coincé parce qu'elle a elle a
licencié florian philippot elle a poussé
dehors lui c'est un peu poussée de aussi
mais en même temps le penseur du front
national qui fait quand même rappeler
mois le nombre de voix qui parvient au
deuxième tour c'était quand même lui à
lorient il ya une impasse conceptuel
peuvent pas aller plus loin ils peuvent
plus reculer donc elle va on va y avoir
5 ans difficile benjamin grange est ce
que ce que vous avez vu sur twitter
corroborent ce qu'on a dit jusqu'à
présent alors totalement mais je vais
aller un petit peu plus loin c'est à
dire que vous êtes on le 9 février
dernier marine le pen avait fait presque
16% de part d'audience sur l'émission
autant là c'est le plus mauvais février
là on est avant même le premier jour de
l'accident
elle avait 16 % de parts de nyons qui
était presque un record pour cette
émission là avec 1,74 million de
spectateurs c'est presque le plus
mauvais scores de l'émission qui est
aujourd'hui tenu par benoît hamon avec
un 70 et en fait donc cruelle
comparaison cruel cruelle comparaison
est d'ailleurs on retrouve le même
phénomène sur les réseaux sociaux au
sens large pas que sur twitter où
finalement le sujet n'intéresse peut à
la fois marine le pen mais également la
manière dont on ne l a fait ce
changement de pied
si on peut s'exprimer comme ça sur sur
sur l'euro avec seulement deux mille
deux mille 2000 messages pendant
l'émission entre 19 et 22 heures ce qui
est ce qui est à peu près 50% de ce qui
s'est passé sur le sur la semaine
c'est à dire en d'autres termes très peu
en comparaison des sujets qu'on a évoqué
juste avant le laurence de charette
c'est une impasse économique
l'absence de choix c'est aussi une
impasse politique pour le front national
puisque comment peut-elle espérer
raccrocher les wagons avec son électorat
en étant aussi flottante
d'ailleurs on voit d'ailleurs dans ce
qu'on vous dit que ce sont les lectorats
pas la vraie le véritable impasse elle
date du débat et le comme le débat
d'entre deux tours des balles entre a
montré et d'ailleurs on en revoyant les
images hier soir à quel point marine le
pen n'était pas présidentiable est donc
quelque part partie à ce moment là
effectivement on a tant de gens ne
s'intéressent beaucoup moins et puis
effectivement on a compris que son
programme avait un avait un flou et hier
elle a pas du tout lever ce flou et elle
est partie sur tous les tableaux sur
l'euro elle a perdu ce qui était pour
ceux qui étaient contre a perdu les deux
camps et sur l'immigration elle a pas
retrouvé un discours très clair non plus
l appât elle n'a pas fait un marqueur ya
donc je pense qu'elle est vraiment à
perdre en plus alors il y en a qui
espère profiter de ce flottement
c'est nicolas dupont aignan cette
journée aujourd'hui puisque c'est le
deuxième extrait de l'émission je vous
propose de le réécouter il était donc ce
matin sur france info
et lui pour le coup il a un programme
assez clair écouter et moi ce que je
veux justement c'est reconstruire un
programme d'alternance pour la france au
delà de boutiques et au delà des
personnalités car ce qu'attendent les
français et je tire les leçons de
l'échec de 2017
ce qu'attendent les français c'est un
programme sérieux et ce programme
sérieux je suis convaincu que les
électeurs républicains debout la france
chrétien démocrate front national sont
capables de santal sur ce programme et
on nous resterons pour le bâtir c'est ça
qui m'intéresse
alors on attend peut-être que
effectivement avec une marine le pen
démonétisé il ya à nouveau une place
pour cette espèce d'alliance à droite
entre peut-être pas le front national
mais en tout cas les républicains dupont
aignan et d'autre oui en même temps
intel une telle guerre des chefs
traditionnels à droite qui en doutent
toujours de la capacité de cette partie
là de
cette partie là du champ politique et à
s'unir donc ça c'est une des grandes
d'hypothèques ses lacets qui sera le
chef
et c'est une bataille presque typique de
la droite pour le coup mais des fois il
ya un chef qui est un leader qui peut
surgir ça arrive de temps en temps il ya
ce moment ça ça devient possible
effectivement ce message si physiquement
d'écarter un charme de deux
personnalités d'un côté ou de l'autre
je ne trouve une go nous demande avec
laurent wauquiez sans sortie de l'euro
marine le pen a plus d espace politique
qu'en pensez vous oui je pense qu'il a
je pense qu'il a raison parce que le
grand concurrent c'est pas nicolas
dupont aignan et laurent wauquiez entame
économique leur en veux qu'ils aient
tient sur l'europe
un discours qui pour l'instant par ses
ambiguïtés et sont en même temps c'est
la version de droite du en même temps
parvient à ne pas braquer ni les pro
européens ni les souverainistes
qu'est ce qu'il dit en très résumé dit
que l'europe telle qu'elle est ne
fonctionne pas c'est un diagnostic avec
lequel absolument tout le monde peut
tomber d'accord et que pour la faire
repartir car il veut la faire partir il
faudrait faire une robe de projets avec
les le petit doigt yeux de pays qui sont
des cités à avancer sur certains points
c'est à peu près inattaquable comme il
n'est pas au pouvoir en plus des ports
on ne demande pas de mettre en oeuvre
ses bonnes résolutions donc c'est assez
confortable pour lui et ça lui parle de
ratisser très large notamment dans le
camp souverainiste ou anti-européens ou
eurosceptique qui se détournent
de marine le pen parce qu'elle ne lui
paraît pas capable d'assumer son projet
prolongée je pense que laurent wauquiez
aussi peut attendre l'éventuel échec des
tentatives de des malais macro et de la
commission huger d'essayer de faire ré
avancer l'europe
là il y en ait dans un moment de thomas
après des élections en amont tombe c'est
vraiment un mot affreux direct non c'est
rachid cdu là on est lancé le moment tom
hervé natures mortes parce que juste
après les élections allemandes on
s'attend à ce qu'il y ait un nouveau il
ya que la construction européennes
repartent de l'avant c'est la volonté de
prise en main du président à un public
français c'est normalement plus ou moins
la volonté d'un gala merkel on sait
qu'ils sont ils sont pas forcément
d'accord la commission newkirk travailla
à fond là dessus mais ça peut très bien
échouer d'ici un ou deux peut-être dans
deux ans tout ça ça va on s'apercevra
que ça n'a rien donné en tête un accord
sur les travailleurs détachés de la
semaine prochaine mais bon sur la zone
euro peut-être qu'on n'arrivera pas
d'accord seulement il peut être je vais
dire savoir le discours de voeux que
wauquiez sera pourra dire dans deux ans
regardez moi j'avais bien vu que cette
europe à 27 voire à 19 avec toute la
zone euro c'est pas possible et à ce
moment-là discours son discours sur une
europe à 608 deviendra de noyaux durs
deviendra peut-être audible par l'un par
le ping voilà peut-être qu'il joue ça ce
qui est vrai c'est que la droite est à
la recherche d' angles d'attaqué contre
la majorité alors il pourrait y avoir
l'europe
il ya aussi en tout cas c'est plus
immédiat le reproche qui est fait au
gouvernement et à l'état en général de
couper les vivres des collectivités
locales les communes les départements
les régions et du coup c'est bien porté
à droite en ce moment d'être proche du
terroir on va venir de voir des photos
de laurent wauquiez dans la campagne
il ya aussi le livre de françois baroin
qui était le patron de la majorité
pendant la la campagne législative qui
écrit un livre assez jolie d'ailleurs
une histoire de france par les villes et
les villages et donc à droite on aime
les territoires et on reproche à la
majorité de ne pas lui donner assez
d'argent
est ce vrai et bien évidemment non
répond edouard philippe c'est le premier
ministre et il était aujourd'hui devant
l'assemblée des départements de france
jamais de question de baisser le volume
des dépenses publiques locales pour une
raison simple c'est que les questions
que les collectivités territoriales
doivent traiter ne sont pas en voie de
contractions alors benjamin grand jeu
devant le sujet un peu technique est ce
qu'il ya une baisse ou non des dotations
mais sur le fond est ce que c'est un
thème qui retrouve un écho chez les ch
et les français l'idée que les
territoires les mairies on n aurait plus
assez d'argent
alors aujourd'hui c'est essentiellement
un sujet qui passionne les leaders
d'opinion et d'ailleurs quand on regarde
dans les sept derniers jours la manière
dont on les français en parlent c'est
majoritairement soit des sites
d'actualités en ligne soit des blogs
d'experts ou de gens qui connaissent
véritablement la thématique est
d'ailleurs quand on essayait de croiser
à la fois le sujet des républicains avec
le sujet des régions des territoires etc
on n'obtient que qu'un infime une infime
partie des messages donc aujourd'hui ce
sujet n'est pas encore passée dans la
sphère du grand public peut-être que
dans les prochaines semaines ce sera le
cas mais on n'a pas encore ce niveau des
coûts la preuve c'est qu'on en parle
d'un point de vue laurence de charette
est ce que l'état s'est désengagé oui
l'état s'est désengagé enfin clairement
il a transféré une une partie des
fonctions sans transférer les budgets
qui allait avec
mais la question est ce que c'est
réellement c'est ce que c'est uniquement
celle là probablement non parce que les
régions et les collectivités locales
globalement
devrait quand même prendre sur elle de
se réorganiser comme l'ensemble de faire
quelques économies de faire quelques
ennemis mais malgré tout ça n'empêchera
pas que macron s'il ne fait pas un pas
vers eux vers l or à l'ère du président
des riches et des villes et que c'est
une histoire d'amour finalement c'est
pas une histoire qu'une histoire de gros
sous
alors c'est intéressant parce que cet
argument il était on l'entend de plus en
plus à droite sur le thème il est coupé
des territoires parce qu'il est coupé du
peuple
il est coupé des vrais gens du monde
rural écoutez ce qu'en dit guillaume
pelletier il est député les républicains
et vice-président du groupe heller à
l'assemblée la question n'est pas là la
question c'est le peuple
la question c'est le monde rural la
question ce sont les petits les sans
voix qu'on écoute jamais et je veux que
tous les audacieux tous les méritants de
francs soit enfin récompensés dans les
quartiers populaires dans le monde rural
est partout sur le territoire national
lauren a tancé la d'abord un est
formidablement macro n'ya point de vue
de l'expression c'est c'est la manière
qui parle à l'impression d'avoir
emmanuel macron avant les élections
problème c'est que les élections sont
passées et sur le flanc est sur le
parquet du pays qu'ils soient laissés de
côté l'autre marque the row pedn
remarque c'est que ça me fait penser au
prix d'un autre et thoune qui disait
qu'il fallait encerclé les villes par
les campagnes et je pense que c'est un
quartier général feu sur le quartier de
l'un et la guerre révolutionnaire
consistait en c'est comme ça après mao
tsé toung a gagné sauf que évidemment
les paysans chinois étaient 90 % de la
population à l'époque où on s'est tous
mis à prix 1 prg il a pris le pouvoir en
moi je pense que le personnel politique
de droite enfin la droite traditionnel
pardon notamment après les élections
c'est naturel s'est aperçue qu'elle
avait encore des bases solides dans les
régions dans dans la ruralité au lac son
personnel a été existait quelques en
face il y avait personne parce
qu'effectivement il n'y a pas personne
non il n'y a pas encore de personnel
local macro n'y un maquereau nice
jusqu'au podium après nuit là il y en
aura pas en 2020 marche
rien n'aura pas avant 2020 parce qu'il
n'y a pas d'élection mais c'est le
municipal qui font apparaître ou pas à
maquereau nice municipal pour le moment
rien à part il payer à quelques
transfuges mais c'est tout voilà et en
attendant ils ont une vraie base et sur
cette base est mal
c'est tout m'a dit on commence par
reculer sur sa base et puis après quand
les mii recul nous attaquons rappel
c'était d'un petit livre rouge
moi je pensais que guillaume pelletier
était plutôt inspiré par patrick buisson
c'est tout mais apparemment il se hisse
voilà heureusement que hervé nathan est
là pour nous ouvrir les yeux puis 21-10
a juste un problème avec cette droite
qui ce qui se fait le défenseur des
territoires globalement je fais quand
même aussi le défenseur des impôts en
disant il faut pas supprimer les emplois
dans les collectivités territoriales
or les électeurs eux ils trouvent que il
faudrait faire des économies peut-être y
compris dans les collectivités les cours
les élus de droite n'hésitent pas à
hurler à la mort quand on leur demande
de prendre leur part de l'effort
d'économie alors les collectivités
locales ont été les plus dépensières
notamment des cantons veut supprimer les
emplois aidés
voilà par exemple ça la dérange pas
d'être d'être contradictoire ce qu'elle
en fait tout ça tout ça est
l'application in vivo du formidable
livre de christophe guilluy qui a été
vraiment cliqué le livre de chevet de
toute politique qui se respecte sur la
france périphérique est d'ailleurs cette
expression de france périphérique et
dans tous les discours on assiste et
laurent wauquiez on aurait pu citer
valérie pécresse dont le nom que le
parent on croise pas forcément à la
campagne quand on mange on imagine
valérie pécresse président de la région
ile de france même s'il ya là la
campagne oui il ya tout à fait enfin bon
c'est pas l'image qui vient à eux donc
il ya vraiment une une politique du
créneau effectivement ces images contre
image
emmanuel macron le président le candidat
puis le président des villes mondialisé
et qui laisse en déshérence des
territoires qui sont déjà très
défavorisés en termes de politique
sociale notamment on a versé beaucoup
plus pendant des décennies dans les
quartiers pauvres urbains que dans le
bourg nettoiera mesure loin que dans les
territoires ruraux ça c'est une réalité
économique et la droite qui se voit
piqué l'essentiel de son programme
économique macroéconomiques par emmanuel
macron est bien contente de trouver un
sujet de rechange et qui correspond à
ses bases électorales
quand vous regardez les députés qui ont
sauvé leur peau fait beaucoup dans ces
territoires
parce que le range at on peut aussi
faire l'opposition peut-être entre la
france et urbaine et puis la france
rurale et puis la france des nantis avec
le président des riches contre contre
ceux qui seraient laissés sur le côté en
tout cas du côté de la gauche c'est
ainsi un ressort qu'on utilise assez
volontiers la france insoumise notamment
oui bah d'ailleurs mal hier marine le
pen faisait du sou mélenchon sur ce
sujet ça départ de paul de la gauche
voilà c'est pas grave c'est plus un
monopole de la gauche et donc c'est
effectivement et c'est c'est un argument
qui qui porte énormément et qui trouve
son parallèle seront disait avec la
france de la ruralité et la france des
villes de la mondialisation et m après
c'est vrai que malgré tout la droite
contre emploi parce que la question qui
se pose c'est également l'ampleur de ces
dépenses c'est pas qui va pas uniquement
qui va payer le rsa mais à quel niveau
en matière du rsa qui va payer les
politiques sociales
mais quelle politique sociale problème
c'est que le rsa dépend de l'état ils
savent assez bien joué puisque les
départements versent le rsa mais il ne
restait fixé par le niveau national
et ça ils savent très bien on voit il ya
deux nounous bilan n'a plus d'argent
dans les caisses pas de notre faute
c'est la faute de l'état ici de la même
façon il puisqu'il ya
preuve de la prise en charge des sans
papiers mais département c'est
évidemment pas les départements qui sont
à l'origine du problème donc voilà vingt
secondes
hervé nathan voc est un spécialiste de
l'économie tome nous pose la question
la suppression de la taxe d'habitation
est elle un coup de massue sur les
territoires à terme oui
à terme oui parce que normalement l'état
doit compenser la lie la rémunération il
a promis mais il a exonéré mais la
promesse c'est quoi c'est de laisser ses
deux c'est la promesse comme va
consister en un apercevoir très vite à
dire je le garantis
les sommes telles qu'elles étaient
versés en 2010 est à partir de 2018
quelle dépense en 2017 2018 2019 en 2007
2008 il ya une adaptation les choses et
services coûtent de plus en plus cher
les et c'est faux les emprunts émis dans
spécial sur la baisse de la hausse parce
que c'est que ses complices est figé on
va cristalliser comme on disait dans le
temps on va figer une somme tellement
imaginons une 9 milliards d'euros c'est
ma prière se sera pas de filière plus
l'inflation l'inflation des déflations
touche aussi les collectivités locales
une question plus importante que celle
de même vis du niveau des ressources
parce que là on ne sait pas on ne sait
pas si l'état va vraiment rester que sa
province ou pas c'est l'autonomie pro
comment 10 la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation c'est de l'autonomie
financière en moi donc de l'autonomie en
moins et d'ailleurs ça donne un aspect
méconnu est pour l'instant pas très
commenté les banales macron c'est son
côté finalement très centralisateur
donc c'est le retour des jacobins c'est
pas évident mais ça pourrait être ça
peut être censurée par le conseil
constitutionnel parce que normalement il
doit y avoir des ressources qui doivent
être au moins la moitié me suis à me
faire moins la moitié des ressources
doivent être à la disposition doivent
être dans la lp doivent être décidées
par les collectivités
c'est pas évident que
c'est qu'elles ont pour des punitions
très sévère nous sommes si elle était la
mesure absolument en tout cas ça c'est
pour l'heure leur leurs dépenses de
fonctionnement
bah écoutez je vous propose de continuer
à parler d'argent mais dans un registre
un peu différent peut-être savez vous
que la fiac qui est le grand rendez vous
européen de l'art contemporain a ouvert
depuis hier ça se passe à paris au grand
palais c'est jusqu'à dimanche
l'art contemporain c'est un sujet qui
est dans l'air du temps mais de façon un
peu critique en ce moment il ya un film
qui a obtenu la palme d'or à cannes qui
s'appelle de square est qui qui sort
cette semaine et qui est une satire de
de l'art contemporain et de de
l'humanisme occidental bontin des bons
sentiments je sens que c'est un très bon
film
en tout cas le figaro magazine a adoré
donc c'est une raison probablement
suffisante pour y aller l'art
contemporain c'est un sujet qui vous
branche laurence de charette vous êtes
vous êtes vous aider ça moi je regrette
beaucoup de ne pas voir une fille parce
que j'ai lu notamment ce passage qu est
ce qui m'a beaucoup amusé sur ce qui
m'amuse beaucoup c'est c'est le terme de
performance que ce soit un terme un peu
pas du tout artistique c'est une espèce
de neuf langues appliquées à l'arrêt
aujourd'hui fait des performances et
cette performance à miami où une jeune
ou en fait une jeune femme a agressé une
autre dans un vieux demande effectué une
performance et personne n'est intervenu
et j'ai envie de voir cette scène dans
le film et en même temps ça ça a réécrit
les un petit peu les les codes de l'or
et ça peut-être c'est intéressant je
refuse de voir une image
il ya une très belle exposition en ce
moment à la fondation vuitton avec des
oeuvres du du musée d'art moderne de new
york moma
la plupart de ces de ses oeuvres sont
absolument incontestable entre
guillemets il y en a d'autres qui sont
intéressants à votre avis qu'est ce que
c'est ça les débits et bien ce sont pas
débiles ce sont des bonbons avoir fait
ce sont des bonbons emballés
individuellement attendu dans du papier
cellophane et le spectateur est invité à
prendre un bonbon une idée ici
fondamentale puisqu'elle implique la
disparition progressive de l'oeuvre
alors c'est à la fois amusant peut-être
un petit peu dérisoire ça vous ça vous
tend sa main quand vous en avez des
oeuvres comme ça chez vous non
j'en ai pas j'en ai pas j'en ai pas
totalement par contre ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que c'est ce que ce que
les internautes disent de la fiac
aujourd'hui il ya pratiquement 25
message s'est passé pas énorme et sur
ses vingt-cinq mille messages
on a beaucoup de choses qui sont assez
neutre parce que on met en avant les
hommes les expositions et a donc
finalement quelque chose d'assez bons
d'assez bon teint et d'assez commercial
et puis à côté de ça on va trouver
quelque chose qui est le pavé dans la
mare série a toujours l'espoir la
polémique
c'est le fameux domestique a tort qui
rien que en soi arriva à presque faire
converger cinq mille 5000 messages en
disant qu'est ce que c'est que ce
domestique à tort la polémique autour où
est ce qu'on va le mettre le fait que
les musées comment dire le louvre et
refuser que pompidou l'accueil etc
et qu'est ce que veut dire cette sodomie
sécateur dont finalement en marge de
tout ce qu'on dit sur la fiac
il ya toujours quelque chose qui va
finalement le mastic à tort parce que
maintenant
alors vous prenez nos réalisateurs de
par surprise on va essayer de trouver
l'image mais en attendant on peut parler
d'un on peut parler d'un autre d'un
autre port de ce sujet eh ben c'est
l'argent parce que la fiac c'est aussi
un marché et l'art contemporain c'est
aussi parfois de la spéculation en tout
cas de l'offre et de la demande je vous
propose d'écouter ce qu'en dit notre
confrère jean gabriel ferez des
journalistes et auteurs du livre qu'un
caniche et autres mystificateur c'était
au micro de marie laetitia bonavita on
écoute les grands perdants ce sont ceux
qui oublient qu'une oeuvre d'art c'est
quelque chose de périssables qu'elle
reflète un goût et qu'elle n'atteint pas
nécessairement l'universalité que ce
qu'ils ont achetée très cher aujourd'hui
il n'est pas du tout certain malgré les
conseils d ardeur et de leur marchand
n'est pas du tout certain que dans dix
ans dans 15 ans le cône sous le murakami
ou le catelet qu'ils ont acheté aura la
même valeur d'un marché qui repose sur
la croyance et la croix alors le comme
le direct primes et on va pas revenir au
sujet précédent mais c'est une
information
tariq ramadan via des tracts d'être
accusé publiquement de viol et
d'agression sexuelle et de harcèlement
par une personne qui s'appelle end ayari
et c'est sur facebook et des salafistes
dont qui a balancé son nom sur sur
facebook
effectivement qui dit l'avoir connue à
la période où elle était salafistes qui
a raconté l'histoire dans un livre
qu'elle a écrit sur cette expérience qui
a duré plusieurs années
je parle de son expérience salafistes
mais sans donner le nom de tariq ramadan
est là comme elle a suscité des
réactions contrastées et notamment de
gens qui lui disent eh ben oui le elle
porte plainte
donc on va avoir des débouchés
judiciaire et on va revenir sur sur ce
sujet des agressions sexuelles dans le
focus qui suivra immédiatement cette
émission avec argane de coeur et
jean-marc le
je reviens à marcq contemporain même si
leur le direct prime wearever l'attend
on disait l'art contemporain c'est de
l'art c'est aussi de l'argent c'est
surtout la la fiac c'est surtout de
l'argent
l'art est très très loin de la fiac une
certaine manière la fiac est un
événement qui considère cela comme
beaucoup de ces foires d'art
contemporain et spécialement pour l'art
contemporain ce sont des événements qui
consiste qui sont faits pour faire
monter la cote
d'une certaine manière on convoque le
public et on convoque les médias et donc
on veux pour mon vont montrer des
expositions en et des objets ce qui
permet ensuite de faire monter la cote
de c2c de ses oeuvres
quelquefois de ces objets passé pas
toujours des oeuvres et quelquefois
c'est des bonbons d'ailleurs mon petit
fils il en a plein son tiroir de cette
oeuvre d'art là si je peux vous dire
sélection ci s'ils pensent que c'est lui
parce que c'est une amateur et efface
son temps effectivement à faire comme
les artistes à dire à diminuer l'oeuvre
d'art mais une certaine manière d'une
certaine manière ce qui est un peu
critiquable
moi à mon sens par exemple de sur
l'histoire de comment il s'appelle 7,4
donc en fait domestique acteurs rentrent
c'est comme ça il faut comprendre
domestique at her même fait sa vie on
vient d'installer maintenant pour créer
un événement dont pour faire un
événement concret une provocation parce
que le domestique at her c'est quand
même assez obscènes en fait quand on
regarde on montrera par des jambons
vient de passer avec 106 en afrique ça
peut être regardée comme quelque chose
d'obscène donc c'est une provocation et
c'est fait pour faire quoi pour qu'on
parle de la fiac et pour les hommes de
la qui sont à l'intérieur de la fiac
voir leur contre leur cote motors
j'étais à la fiac
cette oeuvre est exposée à la fiac en
2010 est l'année de la polémique sur
domestique à tort c'était déjà arrivé
avec
l'oeuvre qui s'appelait tri ces
moments-là il a enfin fait se strient
donc s'appeler noël le ghana le ghana et
qui était plutôt qu'ils se ravisent est
plutôt en français par plug and i'll
voilà qui était plein d'eau installées
place vendôme construction des marchés
parce que des secousses non par les
frais des dans le court extrait vous
avez passé lui a profité à plein des
commandes de versailles notamment
il a exposé à versailles dirty corner et
hop une péniche pour tester une des
spécialités d'art contemporain sous
prétexte de de revisiter les oeuvres
d'art ancien que nous reconnaissons
forcément commode à l'ancienne c'est de
se c'est de se poser à côté c'est
d'occuper les lieux publics où sont les
statuts des oeuvres que nous
reconnaissons comme cette d'artistes
importants cela sauf moi je suis allé à
florence et à florence et à côté du
david de michel-ange mayan statut atroce
de jeff koons qui était dorée sur
tranche comme on peut imaginer que
j'aime beaucoup c'est effectivement il
est resté jusqu'au moment où il ya eu
une offre d'achat
on a aimé rester sur la place de la
signora elle se place de la seigneurie
bon endroit mondialement célèbre elle
est restée jusqu'à au moment où
quelqu'un a mis suffisamment d'argent
pour acheter l'oeuvre de jeff koons qui
était à côté du david de michel-ange
voilà c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne
et en même temps lorsque vous
n'échapperez pas à cette question
c'est pourquoi les domestiques elle tort
ben voilà le voilà le domestique à tort
ville et à l'antenne c'est donc merci à
la régie comme sa réactivité
donc en fait c'est une construction
contemporaine apparemment apparemment
assez banal sauf que vous pouvez y voir
autre chose je laisse ça la réflexion de
nos internautes oui je voulais vous
poser l'expérience de charette en fait
ce débat il a toujours eu lieu dans
l'art des cas quelque chose de nouveau
on dit ah mais c'est commercial c'est
fait pour choquer et puis ensuite c'est
accepter oui allô c'est vrai mais enfin
la fiac a peut-être
est coutumière de ces scandales et je
sais pas si on peut résumer la rade et
scandales en tout cas les dernières
c'est dans les événements parce que j'ai
pas s'il faut appeler ça des expulsions
des hordes et des restes a déjà des je
cherche le bon vocabulaire des
performances à ce que je cherchais nous
nous ont montré qu'à chaque fois ce
qu'on traitait c'était qu'elle est et
quel était l'objet bas on a traité
beaucoup de l'insignifiant l'aspirateur
ou bien de l'absurde ou encore on voit
un grand appétit pour le scatologique ou
pornographiques et la question qui se
pose c'est finalement est-ce que si la
roue et l'art contemporain l'objet c'est
de nous montrer l'âme du monde comme a
dit le directeur de du musée d'art
contemporain est ce qu'on voit mieux la
coupe du monde à travers la pietà de
michel-ange ou à travers le plug annales
de mccarthy et bien c'est une question
qu'on pose existentielle je voulais ce
week-end pour y réfléchir
point de vue qui est une performance en
soi est terminé pour ce soir mais on se
retrouve lundi
merci
[Musique]